I don't even know why this is in here, but okay. On January 21st,
2025, aware of an impending lawsuit and potential criminal investigation,
Bonn starts destroying evidence, including deleting messages
between him and plaintiff. They still they know this is untrue.
I've been able to reproduce everything I have. They've been deleting
messages um and I know she can't reproduce hers cuz she was trying
to hide [__] cuz she knew that she was trying to
extort me. On January 23rd, 205, Bon receives a letter from PL
council informing him of plaint demanding they preserve all evidence.
On about January 23rd, Bon begins to publicly harass and defame
plaintiff.
>> Again, I don't think that's extortion. I don't He keeps
claiming I don't think that's extortion. That does that just
does not
it just does not seem like extortion. Like the the idea that
like you're asking somebody for
money
instead of suing them is a very normal thing that is like
insanely normal within the law. Uh, I don't know where he gets
this from. I think he keeps saying that like because she threatens
suicide that that's the part that makes it extortion and that's
why she deleted the thing about the suicide. But that's not that
that doesn't change anything.